[Music]
connor is with us in youngstown ohio hi
connor how are you
hi dave i'm doing well how about you
good how can we help
hi i just had a quick question about
my wife and i i am 20 and she is
23.
um anyways i'm sorry i wasn't expecting
um
we are currently
going to be needing a
new car or new car soon
why
so i why when i was 18 when i was 18 i
made an 18 year old decision and got a
lease
oh okay and it's going to be up soon
well i still got another year on it
however i went to the toyota dealer and
since the value of cars is so high right
now
they're willing to help you out are they
that's sweet of them
yeah
they said that they would uh
buy out of the lease and i could walk
away from it for you know no cost to me
oh really and not have to buy another
car from
them correct
wow nobody can find cars anymore so
that's an option that i'm you know
considering okay however we are still
paying off debt we have our
obviously our base thousand dollar
emergency fund
but um you know we don't have any extra
money as of right now
what's your household income
before taxes it's about 90 000 between
the both of us good for you
thank you
okay and so how much is your car payment
on the one you're going to turn into
toyota
uh the lease payment is 330 a month
okay
so what if you stopped everything for a
month
how much money could you pile up in a
month if you're in emergency mode
like 3 000 bucks probably right
uh
maybe no not paying extra on anything
just beans and rice
in one month you're making 90 000 a year
yeah before taxes i know
right
you got to be able to get 3 000 bucks
together in a month
okay and then buy a 3 000 car and turn
your toyota in
right
and then the only other thing is so that
that's what i was considering doing and
then the only other thing is that my
wife drives uh her car is a 2012 it only
has 89 000 miles on it but it's the
volkswagen beetle and i can't stand that
car but um
regardless it you know it's had its fair
share of problems and it's
um it still runs good but i just i feel
bad having my wife in
you know the not
you know i mean the husband drives the
crap
in general so yeah you're gonna be
driving a three thousand dollars you are
don't worry we're gonna get you set up
with a crap card yeah we're just putting
you in three things you're both gonna
drive crap cars it's equal opportunity
crap car day
and by the way you're 20 and 23. so
these are the stories you tell your
grandkids
yeah yeah your car's running fine you're
fine she's fine get out of debt then get
yourself out of that get you a 3 000 car
get rid of that leash
drive the bug drive the junker
and and roll up your sleeves and get her
done buddy you can do it you can do it
you'll be out of it before you know it